non-minimalists
we got a question from lisha how will i
know
when i've found the one whoo
yeah man um here i'll give you an
opinion in fact on the maximal i'm gonna
read this excerpt from our forthcoming
book about this the it's called the one
lie because ultimately i think the the
idea of finding the one
i get it there's a lot of romantic
comedies that make me feel like
my wife is the one sure there are other
ones though yeah
if i'm being honest well people who have
been married more than once
right yeah we would tell you that they
thought that first one was the one
yeah and now the second one is the one
and it's interesting too because like
they actually could have been the one
for the for you know for the 10 years
and then i mean [ __ ] changes man people
change it's like it's
yeah so i think i agree with you the the
one is a lie you have to be open to
that person always maybe being the one
but also open to like
maybe they won't be the one one day you
know there's nothing wrong with
approaching a relationship like that i
feel like first i will say you mentioned
romantic comedy and you give me a
mcconaughey failure to launch
vibe
do i yeah
i don't know about the idea of the one
yeah i can tell you this
when i met my wife ten days
later i called my parents and this never
had never talked about marriage before
and i was like i'm marrying her
there was something about her in
specific
that was just different made me feel
differently
than anybody i had ever met and so
um i don't like i don't know
about that and i don't know if god
forbid anything ever happened or we
broke up
if i would ever feel that way about
somebody else i have no idea right i do
know that this
woman was different than any other woman
i had ever met before
and when i met her i don't know if you
know this about me i was a single dad i
was raising three kids right and they're
all
grown now they're all grown um two of
the i had met a woman
early on in my life who had two kids and
we had a kid together
when and when we broke up i kept all
three kids and so when i met
beth um you know that feeling for the
one
oddly enough i had kind of reserved for
my kids
i was like this is where my heart is
gonna be yeah from here on out we're
definitely gonna be talking about that
because uh
yeah i think this idea of love is like
there are different kinds of love
right but and i had never felt when she
when i met her after a couple
that first night i was like this just
must be because i hadn't
been close to a grown woman a long time
this is why i because i had just been
with
three kids and i had in my brain you
know what's funny in my brain
people had always tried to set me up i'm
like hey i'm not going out
i'm at a seven as far as seven to ten
happy
i know what it's like one of these
breakups brings you down to a zero yeah
i'm not willing to go to zero with these
three kids so seven is cool
i'm happy i'm raising these kids they
bring me so much joy there's a part of
my life i'm just gonna
neglect for a while and i was okay with
that because i wasn't
really willing to risk going back down
to that [ __ ] bottom
with the three kids it was just crushing
doing it before
yeah but meeting her right away was like
oh this is a different
yeah this is a different person so yeah
like i agree with you i think ryan and i
both felt that about
our wives as well so but but what i'm
saying with respect to the one in fact
uh dan savage has this great line he
says
there is no one so find your 7.9 that
rounds up to one yeah
right and because you even talked about
how like there are certain things or
when we go talk about aaron's question
the dishes well he's not the one he's
maybe he's the
the 9.7 though that you can round up or
the 0.97 you can round up to a one
and and i think unfortunately looking
for the one sets a really bad
expectation because
it presupposes they're going there's
going to be the perfect
relationship and i think when we're
seeking that we're we're just setting
ourselves up for
tumbling down a hill of discontent i
think romantic comedies do a
complete hollywood does a complete
disservice to actual relationships
yeah because you see these two people
and you're like oh i should feel like
that
and this relationship well it's not that
one that i saw on tv
yeah i'm still waiting for that feeling
and guess what that feeling
doesn't happen like that here's a here's
the bottom line
i'll tell you right now i love my wife i
don't love her enough to stand out in
the rain and kiss her with my jeans on
you know what i mean like that is a
romantic comedy thing you're not gonna
find anybody i like
willing enough to stand out in wet jeans
you know what jeans is the worst feeling
ever
you know what i mean so yeah
so i love you but not wet jeans
oh my god yeah you know what's funny
about those movies is that the
the movie is the story leading up to
that kiss
which is really the beginning of the
relationship yeah it's leading up to
them finally getting together you don't
see the movie
about after they get together and have
kids and have all the other [ __ ] that
happens in life
yeah it's exactly yeah i totally agree
man it's it's a bit of a disservice
because that
feeling you might be able to capture
that you know kissing someone in the
rain feeling
but that's that's that's not gonna last
forever that is a that's a pleasure that
is ephemeral and it's okay to feel that
pleasure
but to expect to feel that pleasure 100
of the time up until the day you die
like that's that's
what it is right is that is that it's
not that that
pleasure might not you might not get it
for a second but to expect your
relationship
day in and day out to be this fairy tale
and not to i think people pull the plug
on relationships
to marriages especially too quickly now
yeah
like as soon as there's one lull yeah
they think well that's the [ __ ] end
of the relationship right
does it but you're gonna have lulls yeah
you just gotta ride them out together
like we've been together since 2001
there have been a lot of ebbs yeah right
but you just have to go this is an app i
think you got to make sure you're still
compatible though
our friend dr christopher ryan he he
talks about
the three things that are necessary in a
relationship so instead of looking for
the one i'd probably look for these
three things
first off is chemistry and i think
that's what you're talking about when
you when you met your wife's first day
of course there's chemistry right yeah
we often mistake lust for love
um but i think there's chemistry in
other relationships as well non-sexual
relationship like ryan i have a
particular chemistry we even use those
terms right
when we're talking so any relationship
has chemistry any relationship has
love any good relationship at least in
any relationship has compatibility
those three things are required i think
the problem quite often is
that we hope we get into a relationship
because one or maybe even two of those
are working right it's just
the chemistry it's there we're all over
each other all day it's great
and yeah of course i love her i have
this deep affection for
this person right but then you realize
like oh no we're not compatible and
there could be a thousand
thousand reasons why you're not
compatible like if uh your wife is like
no i hate kids i never want to see a kid
in my life you'd be like well that's
going to be kind of a problem for us
right
three people can just put a blanket on
them
right have a packing party with them
tell me what time they go to sleep i'll
be over after that
right and so i think we have to realize
that like quite often
we're not compatible now there are other
things that happen as well we get into
toxic relationships then
of course you want to abandon that as
soon as you can if someone is behaving
in a toxic way
whether it's verbal abuse or god forbid
violence or something
let go of that um because that rage
stems from a deep sort of insecurity or
immaturity
as do any of our sort of anger issues i
think they often stem from
this place of of insecurity yeah i think
ultimately though
uh alicia you wanna you wanna realize
that you are complete in an empty room
right and so whoever you bring into your
life they're going to
enhance or augment or amplify your
experience of life
they're not going to complete you
they're not the one that completes you
you're already complete yeah i totally
agree uh
so we've had time to prepare for this uh
answer so um
we've got yeah we've got some pithy
stuff ready mine is love from another is
not a substitute for self-love
and i think um people they often tell
themselves if i find the one then my
life is going to be complete
and it's really what i'm saying the same
thing as josh is you have to be really
comfortable with yourself
and then you can bring someone in to
like amplify your life
but love from someone else is not going
to
uh it's not going to be a substitute for
that love that you need to have for
yourself or that acceptance
that you need to have for yourself even
though it seems like a really easy fix
like oh man i got a bad life i really
don't like who i am i need to find
someone who loves me
that'll make me feel good uh sometimes
it actually makes you feel worse
because then you got someone who loves
you and who's treating you well but you
still don't feel like you deserve that
love so then that comes out in other
ways
josh have you ever felt like you got
into a relationship or known anyone
who's gone to a relationship
who didn't really much like themselves
and they thought that it was going to
fix them
in a way oh yeah you know
one of my hmm
it's so it's a
okay there's somebody who's very close
to me i'm not gonna you don't say we
won't go your name yeah but
uh it's tim from a friend of a friend
it's
it's heartbreaking for me um
because she is incredibly unhappy with
who she is
and has turned to
um alcohol and dudes
to try to fill that hole
yeah and has is willing to
do things that she doesn't like and is
willing to be a person that she doesn't
want to be
in order to keep somebody's love and
it's heartbreaking for me to watch
because and it the the thing that really
makes you beat your head against a wall
which is like how come that person
doesn't see
and it doesn't matter how many times you
say it to them i wish you saw
what we see when you look at yourself in
the mirror
but she doesn't she has zero self-worth
she has zero feelings that she's lovable
or that she's
worth love and so she's constantly
chasing it from
people and because of that is never
finds it
because at the end of the day she's
always feeling empty yeah you can't fill
a hole with a cup in it
or a cup with a hole in it yeah yeah
yeah yeah but i like the other way yeah
hole with a couple yeah that's great but
but i
i too you know i battle a little bit
with depression
and i can feel it coming and even though
i'm
cognizant of it and i know when i'm in
it
um i'm always looking for other things
or
and so when i'm depressed i smoke more
weed or
whatever it is to fill phil phil so i'm
the reason i see it so much in her and
it's so heartbreaking i feel it for like
maybe a week every it's dark those are
dark deep places
when i talk to her she's like this is
where i am all the time damn
all the time yeah and so it's really
heartbreaking to know that she's
she feels stuck and i and there's
nothing that i feel like
that anybody from the outside can really
do until she gets
tired of feeling that way i don't know
how to
if she can be you know your instinct is
to rescue or to go help and
so it's a really tough situation for me
and beth
because we're both super close to her
and and uh feel super helpless but
just watch from the outside as that
drain just gets
circled all the time you know yeah i
don't know like do you
is there any i mean it's i think once
you're in that a place like that like
you have to
you have to stop bringing in external
things to try and fill that hole
so how do you get her to that point like
someone someone is not going to get to
help until they want help
and the help that i would recommend for
someone like that is
you gotta surround yourself with like an
awesome community so whether that's like
a racquetball club yeah or church
whatever it is like find a community
that you that a supportive community
that you can get behind
and go talk to a professional man like
there are i gotta i got it
awesome therapist and i'm telling you
having a good therapist
is like one of the best tools that you
can have in life she
lies to her therapist yeah she's gotta
be honest first
she lies through her therapist she likes
herself the only therapist
that stuck i finally found out you're
stuck because
the therapist wasn't challenging her
so she was lying to the therapist and
telling
i would talk to the therapist and be
like what's the deal and she said well
this is what she's saying and
i was like this is not the truth yeah
and you're letting her get away
with that so so there's no honesty
in the safest place possible there's no
honesty
it's been really tough to watch um
because you're constantly
cha you think somebody else's love is
gonna make you whole
and it's just but because
that person who's chasing that love
always finds unhealthy love
yeah because she's willing to be treated
in whatever manner that person wants to
treat her
as long as he stays there yeah there
there's a
there's just there's a temporary thing
that she's obviously getting from the
alcohol and from the men
and that's just it's temporary that's
why she just continues to go after it
but
it makes me think i had a family
relative who
uh they were addicted to heroin had a
few family relatives addicted heroin
um and this this parent of this family
member brought me in and they're like
dude he's off the rails like we just
tell him something to
to help him and i'm looking at him and
he's just like oh it's uh
what's up and i i'm like there's nothing
to do here like this kid does not want
help
like there is there is no there's
nothing for me to say to this person
like they don't want
help they're gonna i could i could give
them the best tony robbins speech that
they've
ever heard right now like the most
motivational speech that this person has
ever heard
but i can see that they don't want the
help so no matter how much help you give
someone if they don't want it like
they're never gonna fix themselves
she's gotta start being honest with
herself but until she wants to change
like what are you gonna do you can't
force someone to be honest with you you
can't you can't you can't drag him
or her kicking and screaming to success
right like i'm
i'm going to make you successful i'm
going to make you
whatever it goes back to the whole thing
you can't change the
people around you can't actually change
someone unless they're trying to change
i don't think people actually hate
change though they hate being changed
we all like good changes right like if
all of a sudden you look in your banking
account there's an extra hundred
thousand dollars in there i love this
kind of change like
is there something you want to tell me
yeah you're the 100th guest
or you get a pair of pants out and
there's like a pocketful of change in
there you're like i love this change
well i mean it's heartbreaking to watch
someone you love
not you know you want to shake change
into them
but you can you know i've had addicts in
my family and like it's heartbreaking to
watch
but you you do realize like there's
nothing i can do to change
this goes back to that question for the
woman washing the dishes there's nothing
i can do
to change you zero things that i'm going
to say
is going to change who you are it might
change my behavior temporarily
yeah i'm going to feel a resentment
because of it though and and that's
the resentment's obviously never good
for the relationship
you